اه يعني شيء كثير يعني انا من الناس اللي
سعيدين بهذا التعاقد لانه سينعكس على
الكره السعوديه والرياضه السعوديه بشكل
عام يعني هي تعاقد تاريخي لاول مره في
تاريخ الكره السعوديه يتعاقد في فريق مع
لاعب حصل على افضل لاعب في العالم خمس
مرات ولاعب لديه كاريزما ولديه شخصيه بكل
تاكيد الفوائد لا تعد ولا تحصى ولكن فيه
فوائد قصيره اجل وفي فوائد ستكون طويله
اجل ممكن نشوفها مع بدايه ما يلعب في
الدوري السعودي واستمرار عكس على الارث
والاثر اللي بيحقق كريستيانو وتاثر كثير
من اللاعبين لكن
خلينا نتكلم بسرعه الفوائد السريعه اول
فائده انا اعتقد انه هذا سيفتح الباب
لمزيد من نجوم العالم ان يحضروا للدوري
السعودي وهذا شيء نعرف انه الانديه
السعوديه احيانا تعاني مع لاعبين الصف
الاول او حتى الصف الثاني في اوروبا
يعني استقطاعهم لانه منطقه جديده والشرق
الاوسط غير معروف لكثير من اللاعبين فلذلك
عندما ياتي لاعب بحجم كريستيانو رونالدو
للمنطقه ما في شك انه يعني جميع لاعبين
العالم سيكونون على الاقل يفكرون في هذا
الموضوع اعتقد انه اول حاجه جديده
اللي ممكن ياتي راموس عدد من اللاعبين
سواريز كان ممكن ياتي ولكن كما نعلم انها
منطقه جديده ممكن ما في لاعبين يخاطرون
يكون عندهم الخطوه الاولى ولكن لما يكون
كريستيانو موجود ما في شك انه بقيه
اللاعبين قد يحضرون وهذا انعكاس ايضا على
قيمه السوق قيمه ال- همم الدوري السوقيه
يعني ستكون مرتفعه جدا بوجود كريستيانو
رونالدو اضافه للناشئين الشباب اللي ممكن
يتاثرون بهذا اللاعب من طريقه لعبه اضافه
الى الاحترافيه يعني اللاعب لديه احترافيه
غير عاديه 37 سنه ما زال يتمرن وكانه في
بدايه بنفس الحماس بنفس الشقق اتمنى ان
ينعكس اللاعب السعودي وان يكون بنفس
الحماس ونفس الشغف ونفس الاحترافيه فهي
صفقه ميسون رائع جدا واستنكس ليس فقط على
هذه الناصر
ولكن تاكيد
ترى ضيقه اقصد بشكل عام الناس قد يعني
تنظر لها ان هذا اللاعب مش في النادي اللي
انا امين لا ممكن اكون مش مع الصفقه او ضد
صفقه ولكن اعتقد انها ستنعكس على الكره
السعوديه وعلى الدوري السعودي وعلى قيمته
اضافه المتابعه الاعلاميه ستكون زخم
اعلامي كبير وستضع الدوري السعودي على
خارطه يعني الدوريات المتابعه على مستوى
العالم وليس فقط على مستوى يعني العربي
والخليجيين
للاعب للنادي للمنتخب
اكيد يعني
الجماهير في الغالب من الانديه وتحب
اللاعب لما يكون موجود في النادي وعندما
يخرج في النادي همم يعني قد يكون لاعب
يعني همم لا يلقى نفسه الحب ولكن ايضا
شفنا لاعبين كثير جاءوا لعندها وجابوا
معهم جماهيريتهم
وحب الناس لهم في كل تاكيد حتى قيمه نادي
النصر ستكون اكبر وشعبيه ستكون اكبر
بشكل عام يعني اعتقد المتابعه مباريات
الدوري السعودي من الجميع حبا في
كريستيانو رونالدو وستنعكس على الجميع
وليس فقط على نادي النصر واعلام
ولا عم تحكي على مستوى محلي ايضا بمعنى
اخر النصر ربما سيسرق بعد مشجعين نادي
اخرى
محليا اعتقد ان تاثير سيكون بنفس الحجم
اللي دوريه عندما يعني يستقبل النصر هذا
اللاعب وهو لاعب يعني ايقونه لاعب يعني
على مستوى العالم هذه همم تجذب لك
الجماهير والمتابعين وانا عارف انه همم
يعني ناس كثير على السوشل ميديا ولديه
يعني عدد كبير يصل نصف مليار هذه النوعيه
من الجماهير بكل تاكيد تهتم بتفاصيل
كرستيانو رونالدو اليوميه فما بالك- بعد
في الملعب بكل تاكيد اليوم الكره السعوديه
والدوري السعودي سينتقل من المرحله
الخليجيه والعربيه وحتى الشرق الاوسط الى
يعني الاهتمام العالمي هل نتحدث عن
النوادي ان لديها طريقه معينه باللاعب
وبالتالي عليه ان يتاقلم مع طريقه النصر
او لا هو الذي سيحول همم طريقه اللعب كونه
لاعب عالمي يعني بهذا الايطالي
تكون كبيره ولكن في الغالب النجوم لما
يحضرون نجم لل حجم كريستيانو وام ميسي او
اللاعبين اللي هم اصلا تبنا طريقه اللعب
وخطه المدرب ويعني اختيار للاسلوب الامثل
على اللاعب وعلى النجم كريستيانو رونالدو
من اللاعبين لتدمي الخطه عليه ولا اعتقد
انه يعني سنرى النصر اخر ومختلف واداء
مختلف مع كريستيانو
كيف يمكن تطبيقه ولا اي حد راح يكون في
فرحه من ضمن اللاعبين لوجوده كونه شخصيه
بهذا الحجم ولكن بالمقابل ايضا منافس
بالنسبه لهم همم وهذه صحتهم اذا ما صحه
تعبير
شو صعب ان احنا الان نتوقع ايش بيصير وردت
اللاعبين ورده فعله رونالدو
همم تشريف لاي لاعب ولكن مدى تفاعلهم بشكل
جيد قدرتهم على التعامل مع هذه اشياء
كثيره نحتاج لوقت عشان نستوعبها ترى الخبر
بالنسبه لنا خبر اكبر من ان احنا نستوعب
بهذه السهوله فايضا اللاعبين ردت فعلهم
وتفاعلهم مع اللاعب
وقدرتهم على التعاون مع بشكل كبير هذه
تحتاج الى وقت ولكن اعتقد انه اللاعبين
سيكون اسعد الناس لانه كريستيانو
وايضا قيمه الفنيه لا احنا نتكلم
على بقيه العين
لدينا معلومات او لا سر للغايه
قيمه الماليه
هذه غير معلنه ما زالت الى الان نحن ننتظر
الاخبار نبغى نشوف وش القيمه الماليه وش
الدين وكل التفاصيل الاخرى ولكن مهما دفع
اللي لاعب مثل كريستيانو رونالدو اعتقدنا
اقل من حقه